hablamos de salud en directo américa de
france 24 y me acompaña por más romeros
a la marina sardina marina bienvenida a
nuestro programa de esta mesa de trabajo
hoy decidimos entonces dedicar el
espacio de salud para hablar de los usos
medicinales del cannabis es que el
pasado miércoles menta abril o sea el
día si hacer las tijeras porque ayer
pues jueves se celebró el día
internacional de la marihuana pero
nosotros vamos a hablar de la marihuana
recreacional sino de los gustos
terapéuticos de esta planta marina cuál
es la diferencia entre medicinal y
recreacional buenos días y nosotros
vamos a hablar de la medicina el
cannabinoide o de las plantas del
cannabis no le vamos a dar una
aclaración la marihuana y el cannabis
son la misma planta cannabis sátiva pero
en términos médicos que utilizan el
término cannabis para referirse a los
componentes cannabinoides de esta planta
y sus usos medicinales
es el cannabis tiene más de 100
componentes cannabinoides pero hay dos
que son los principales
veamos repasemos cuáles son estos
compuestos y cuáles son sus diferencias
hablamos del tetrahidrocannabinol thc
y del cannabis cannabidiol cbd
ambos pueden ser usados en contextos
terapéuticos o recreacionales no pero en
este caso estamos hablando de el sistema
de curso médico ambos actúan sobre el
sistema endocannabinoide que tienen en
común todos los mamíferos incluyendo los
seres humanos es una especie de sistema
de comunicación intercelular que digamos
raúl que es como una especie de
receptores que que atraen estos
cannabinoides y que se encuentran en el
sistema nervioso central y inmunológico
que tenemos todos los seres humanos y
los mamíferos el thc es un componente
psicoactivo del cannabis y aquí hablamos
de las diferencias entre el thc y el cbd
es más frecuente en su uso recreacional
pero también se puede usar en términos
médicos pues por ejemplo en pacientes
con cáncer o con vih para estimular el
apetito mientras que el cbd
estos efectos psicoactivos sino que es
también un antiinflamatorio también se
usa con pacientes que tienen ansiedad y
por lo tanto pues lo podemos encontrar
no sé si quizás lo has visto en las
farmacias en otros lugares en forma de
aceites o de cremas marina y cuáles son
sus usos médicos qué enfermedades se
pueden tratar entonces con el cannabis
medicinal hablamos del cb desierto
marina bueno hablamos de ambos no se
pueden usar en el contexto médico para
tratar a pacientes con enfermedades
crónicas esto quiere decir son pacientes
que tienen dolencias que llevan que se
perpetúan durante meses o incluso años
no también por ejemplo en niños con
epilepsia que no responden a los
tratamientos farmacológicos
tradicionales y hablamos recientemente
con la doctora paola cubillos ella es
especialista en medicina integrativa y
experta en medicina cannabinoide sobre
los otros usos médicos y nos cuenta
o los derivados de la planta del
cannabis tienen un potencial terapéutico
en el manejo de enfermedades
neurológicas como la esclerosis múltiple
que es una enfermedad autoinmune en la
que las células nerviosas
se interrumpe su comunicación de la una
a la otra y a esto va a desencadenar una
serie de síntomas neurológicos como son
la espasticidad como son dolor como por
pérdida del control de la orina por
ejemplo y en algunos de estos pacientes
se ha demostrado que los derivados del
cannabis también pueden aliviar en
particular la espasticidad / la rigidez
muscular y también el dolor que puede
acompañar esta enfermedad también se ha
demostrado que un componente en
particular de la planta del cannabis el
tetrahidrocannabinol tiene un potencial
interesante en tratar en la náusea y el
vómito que está relacionado con los
tratamientos para cáncer con la
quimioterapia manera entonces le quiero
preguntar si este tratamiento sirve para
todo tipo de pacientes o cuáles son las
contraindicaciones porque como todo
medicamento hay contraindicaciones en
este ambiente raúl como todo el
medicamento con el los cannabinoides
también hay contraindicaciones indicas e
indicaciones no depende de las
condiciones clínicas del paciente que
podrían ser tratadas tanto con el cbd
como con el thc y así nos lo explicó
también la doctora
utilización de productos que contengan
tetrahidrocannabinol estaría
contraindicado en personas que tienen
enfermedades psiquiátricas en particular
esquizofrenia o enfermedad bipolar este
mismo compuesto también el
tetrahidrocannabinol está contraindicado
en personas menores de 25 años porque
sabemos que tiene un impacto en el
desarrollo neuronal en el desarrollo
cerebral con respecto al cannabis es la
otra molécula que contiene generalmente
los derivados del cannabis los productos
derivados del cannabis estaría una una
precaución más que una
contraindicaciones aquellas personas que
ya tengan enfermedad hepática y por
supuesto la pregunta marina porque si
conocemos todos estos usos médicos y
contraindicaciones porque sigue
existiendo una estima una
estigmatización digamos en esta medicina
bueno me gustaría también aclarar por
ejemplo que el thc no está recomendado
que no lo dijo la doctora son mujeres
embarazadas en lactantes o en personas
que quieren tener un embarazo puesto que
puede ser perjudicial y el cb de no es
recomendable en pacientes que están
tomando medicamentos
segmentos porque se ha demostrado que
puede incidir sobre ellos en cuanto a
los estigmas pues cada vez son menos es
cierto que en toda américa desde canadá
hasta argentina los países están
legalizando el uso médico de los
cannabinoides pero todavía pues hay una
especie de reticencia porque se asocia
el uso recreativo con la marihuana con
este uso medicinal también de eso
hablamos con la doctora paula desde el
punto de vista de los retos para
trabajar con estas moléculas es que
todavía existe mucho desconocimiento de
muchas áreas del conocimiento que
todavía están por llenarse nos falta
muchísima investigación para conocer por
ejemplo cuáles son las ventajas de
utilizar derivados del cannabis frente a
otros fármacos esos tipos de estudios no
los hemos hecho aún hay un gran
desconocimiento en el gremio médico y en
otras profesiones médicas aliadas en
cuáles puedan ser los impactos tanto
positivos como negativos de la
utilización de los medicamentos como
deben tratarse los compuestos derivados
de la planta del cannabis para uso
médico
marina pues como vemos todavía queda
mucha investigación por delante
recordemos raúl que es un tratamiento
recientemente nuevo es una terapia que
está en proceso de desarrollo y que se
necesita más investigación para ver pero
como dicen los doctores es una terapia
una modalidad médica que ha llegado para
quedarse una alternativa marina y lo
vemos cada día más gracias entonces por
toda esta información de nuestra crónica
de salud hoy en reemplazo de más remeros
a las gracias marina un abrazo feliz fin
de semana pasamos a saludar a nuestro
segundo invitado el día